[Music]
see you've entertained us through our
kids and teen years but where our
favorite former Disney Channel stars now
watch until the end to find out what a
certain descendants 3 star is doing now
zendaya zendaya coleman got her big
break as a disney star at just 14 years
old she's come a long way since her
roles in Disney Channel's shake it up
and Casey under cover so what's she been
up to lately
well for starters zendaya wrote a book
to help teens build confidence she's
been in Taylor Swift's and Beyonce's
music videos and she's currently
starring in the HBO series euphoria
watch for her in an upcoming crime
thriller alongside Jake Gyllenhaal -
kind and a new film about Anita Hemmings
called a white lie Miley Cyrus we all
got to know Miley Cyrus on the Disney
Channel many years ago she played the
role of Hannah Montana a normal teenage
girl with a secret popstar identity
since then she has had a very successful
music career but it hasn't all been
roses she lost her home to the
devastating Woolsey wildfire in
California after that she married her
longtime fiance Liam Hemsworth Miley is
releasing a trilogy of six-track EP s
this year that defines a new era for
Miley Peyton list we know Peyton for her
appearance in the Disney Channel series
Jesse and its subsequent spinoff Punk'd
but what has she been up to since she
decided to leave the Disney Channel for
good well she's appearing in the second
season of YouTube bread's Cobra Kai she
also starred in The CW comedy series
glamorous but she didn't stop at TV
she's also in the rom-com movie then
came you and a thriller called anthem of
a teenage prophet Satan is also a singer
and recently released the electric pop
single liar liar debby ryan who can
forget debby ryan from the hit Disney
Channel show Jesse and the suite life on
deck she started out at just 15 years
old now over a decade later she's
working on the new Netflix series
insatiable it's a dark comedy that was
just too tempting for Debbie to pass up
debbie was ready to take a break from
television when she came across the
script / insatiable she said it was a
story that made her feel seen and heard
and also
laughs it's the perfect role for her to
break out of the Disney mold dylan and
Cole Sprouse dylan and Cole Sprouse came
onto the Disney scene with The Suite
Life of Zack and Cody it's spinoff
series the suite life on deck and of
course The Suite Life movie since their
time on the Disney Channel the Sprouse
brothers have been working apart Cole
Sprouse landed a role as Jughead on
Riverdale
meanwhile dylan sprouse appeared in a
camilla Kibeho music video the app
definitely changed a lot since their
Zack & Cody days most recently Cole
starred in the teen romance drama 5 feet
apart
Dylan is set to star in the 90s
adventure films Tyger Tyger Skye Jackson
Skye Jackson played the adorable Zuri
Ross in the Disney Channel's Jessie and
also starred in the spin-off Punk'd
since then she has been growing up and
working to empower and inspire others in
fact guy has a book coming out soon
called reach for the sky how to inspire
empower and clap back in the books Kai
shares important life lesson she learned
she also discusses her rise to stardom
her memoir emphasizes self-acceptance
rural empowerment and the classy clap
back Laura Marano
ever wonder what Laura Marano has been
up to since Disney Channel's Austin and
Ally
well quite a lot actually she's been
working on some new music additionally
she starred in four different films
including Lady Bird I'll be next door
for Christmas and the war with grandpa
starring Robert De Niro she also starred
in saving Zoey a film in which she
appears alongside her sister Vanessa
Marano
Flores not slowing down anytime soon
Sabrina carpenter bam snow Sabrina
carpenter as the funny rebellious best
friend in Disney Channel's Girl Meets
World she spent most of her teen years
on that show but since the show has
ended Sabrina plans to dive into more
dramatic roles the first of those would
be the not so likeable character Hayley
in the drama the hate you give she's
also working on her third dance album
singular which is set to come out later
this year she's enjoying the view
outside the Disney verse dove Cameron
Disney's Liv and Maddie and descendants
star has come a long way since the start
of it all she has won an Emmy
and been working on a music career but
most recently dev has taken to this
stage she starred as the original share
in clueless
the musical and is about to finish the
London run of the show light in the
Piazza as Clara while she has struggled
with the celebrity element of her career
she doesn't seem to be stopping or
slowing down and with Disney's
descendants three coming out this August
there's no chance fans will be
forgetting about her anytime soon which
Disney Channel star on this list is your
favorite tell us in the comments be sure
to subscribe to the things to get the
latest scoop on your favorite Disney
Channel stars and much more and give
this video a big thumbs up thanks for
watching
see you soon
[Music]